bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
sur ce si le gosse
il ya quelques jours sur instagram je
vous ai demandé si vous aviez des
questions au sujet de la thèse vous
m'avez donc envoyé tout ça et je vais y
répondre dans cette vidéo de répartir
vos questions en deux catégories la
première concerne la décision de
commencer un doctorat donc autant sur le
côté administratif que sur les
motivations et sur ce qui m'a poussé à
aller vers le doctorat et la seconde
catégorie concerne plutôt l'organisation
la motivation au quotidien une fois
qu'on a une thèse vous pouvez retrouver
les chapitres correspondant à ces deux
catégories dans la barre de temps sous
cette vidéo c'est donc parti pour la
première catégorie à savoir s'inscrire
en doctorat pourquoi il commet alors
tout d'abord on m'a demandé pourquoi
faire un doctorat
les raisons sont propres à chacun et
chacune
mais quand on fait un doctorat du moins
en sciences sociales c'est souvent parce
qu'on veut continuer dans une carrière
universitaire ou du moins à court terme
on veut faire de la recherche il ya des
jeunes docteurs qui ne poursuivent pas
leur carrière dans le milieu
universitaire à la suite de leur
soutenance le doctorat c'est donc un
diplôme qu'on obtient une fois qu'on a
soutenu sa thèse de doctorat c'est en
moyenne 4 5 ans en sciences sociales le
temps de réaliser une thèse donc voilà
on fait pas ça juste pour le diplôme
c'est pas le genre de diplômes qu on
fait juste pour avoir un diplôme je vous
le dit d'entrée de jeu ça implique
beaucoup trop d'investissements de
difficultés potentielles et de et
d'instabilité tout simplement pour que
ce soit juste pour avoir un titre en
plus au niveau universitaire alors après
à titre personnel pourquoi est-ce que
j'ai décidé de me lancer en doctorat est
bien passé parce que j'adore la
recherche tout simplement j'adore la
recherche j'aime beaucoup aussi enseigné
même si pour le moment j'enseigne pas à
la fac c'est quelque chose que j'aime
faire que j'ai découvert en masters
grâce aux mémoires de recherche est en
fête
j'ai trouvé l'équilibré entre eux
l'écriture académies entre la recherche
de terrains entre aussi le fait d'aller
creuser sur un sujet très précis
jusqu'au fond du sujet de montrer des
universitaires rencontrer les gens à qui
on travaille les enquêtés voilà tout ça
puis tout ça dans un environnement
intellectuel hyper stimulant moi c'est
quelque chose qui me plaisait beaucoup
m'attirait beaucoup donc c'est pour ça
que je me suis lancé dans ce chemin
c'est pour pouvoir faire de la recherche
au quotidien et espérer évoluer dans le
milieu universitaire ensuite la seconde
question qu'on m'a posée c'est est ce
que tu a d'abord pensé à faire une thèse
ou est ce que tu as vu le sujet et tu
l'a transformé en thèse alors dans mon
cas j'avais déjà un sujet ou du moins
une thématique est gelée travailler pour
en faire un projet de texte ça c'est pas
possible en fait de commencer une thèse
sans avoir de sujet après la manière
dans le sujet et formuler ou la merde on
traite le sujet va évoluer au fur et à
mesure du doctorat mais pour s'inscrire
en thèse eh bien il faut présenter un
projet de thèse donc on est obligé
d'avoir un sujet dans mon cas je dirais
que c'est à la fois l'exercice du
mémoire de master qui m'a fait un déclic
et en plus la passion pour mon sujet qui
m'a entraîné vers vers le choix du
docteur ensuite comment choisir un bon
sujet alors c'est pas une question
facile mais comme conseil ce que je
dirais c'est d'abord d'aller vers un une
thématique qui vous tient à coeur qui
vous intéresse vraiment qui vous
passionne qui sur laquelle vous pouvez
lire et écrire pendant des heures et des
heures sans cerveau soul parce que le
doctorat c'est un parcours de longue
haleine et donc si on n'est pas
intéressé
par son sujet pas ça peut être j'imagine
un peu compliqué après ça dépend
évidemment de vos disciplines extra mais
c'est vrai qu'en sciences sociales moi
je conseillerais d'aller vers un sujet
qui nous touche parce qu'on y voit à
quelque chose de 2 des différends
d'inédits et qu'on aimerait comprendre
plus en détail voilà un une thématique à
un problème de société dont on aimerait
mieux comprendre les mécanismes
je pense que c'est ça le plus important
sachant que ce qui est selon moi la
meilleure manière de trouver un sujet
c'est aussi de le faire émerger du
terrain partir d'une réalité matérielle
quelque chose qu'on a vu qu'on a
observés sur le terrain plutôt que
quelque chose qu'on a lu quelque part et
que on imagine que ça se passe comme ça
voilà je pense que ça évite d'avoir trop
de biais et de projeter des limbes
l'importance de certaines choses qui
finalement ne le sont pas tant que ça
dans la réalité
j'ai passé très classe que je dis mais
voilà c'est s'il ya un sujet qui vous
intéresse allez rencontrer les personnes
qui font vivre cette ce problème social
parler avec eux et elles et puis à
partir de là vous allez pouvoir
construire un sujet et puis surtout pour
toi mon sujet de thèse je dirais qu'il
faut étudier la faisabilité de la
recherche par rapport à vos compétences
tout simplement par exemple les
compétences linguistiques les capacités
d'accès au terrain il ya des terrains
qui sont pas accessibles tout court
parce que ce sont des zones dangereuses
de conflit et serra il ya des terrains
qui ne sont pas accessibles parce que
j'espère vous êtes un homme vous at il
pas mettre nos droits on ne peut pas
aller où par exemple si vous voulez
travailler dans les hautes sphères de la
diplomatie bah si vous n'avez pas du
tout de contact de possibilités d'accès
ça peut rendre votre votre enquête
compliquée ou de même c'est dans un
autre pays dans des sphères très
particulière voilà il faut se poser la
question de la faisabilité
parce que alors même si rien est
impossible le fait que votre chère je ne
soit pas faisable déjà ça ne va pas la
rendre possible en pour vous de le
réaliser et surtout vous n'allez vous
allez avoir du mal à obtenir des
financement etc parce que on voit bien
qu un problème dans la possibilité de
passer à l'action et de réaliser votre
recherche ensuite on m'a demandé faut-il
nécessairement avoir plus de 17 sur 20 à
son master de recherche pour espérer
faire une thèse alors c'est un peu plus
compliqué que cela c'est pas question
d'avoir des assurant à son masque mais
en effet il ya des critères de sélection
a fondé sur le masters je vais parler de
la plupart des facs évidemment il y à
des exceptions et puis dans d'autres
pays moi je parle de la france et de la
plupart des facs en sciences sociales
voilà donc le premier critère c'est
d'avoir fini est donc d'être titulaire
d'un master de recherche donc c'est
hyper important d'avoir la mention
master de recherche parce que c'est
nécessaire c'est requis pour que la
plupart des écoles doctorales quel on va
s'inscrire donc voilà est titulaire d'un
master de recherche même s'il ya des
exceptions et il me semble que la
plupart des écoles doctorales demande
que ce master et été obtenu avec la
mention très bien de ce qui correspond à
une moyenne de 16 sur 20 minimum il ya
d'un côté la mention très bien en master
donc sur les deux années de master et de
l'autre côté il y à aussi la
l'obtention d'une note supérieure à 16
sur 20 aux mémoires de recherche parce
que matt simplement le doctorat souvent
c'est le prolongement du mémoire de
recherche c'est aussi une recherche qui
valait que beaucoup plus longue et plus
complexe à mener donc qu'ils estiment
que si vous n'avez pas eu plus de ça sur
vingt en mémoire de recharge n'a pas
forcément prêt à poursuivre en doctorat
la mission en doctorat il encadrer par
les critères de sélection et en plus
après il faut présenter un projet de
thèse et obtenir l'autorisation
d'inscription dans une école doctorale
mais là je vous invite vraiment à vous
rapprocher de vos universités parce que
ça peut changer ensuite on m'a posé la
question épineuse elles sont les moyens
de financement pour une thèse alors je
dirais qu'il ya trois manières principal
de financer une thèse en sciences
sociales en france
la première ça va être l'obtention d'un
contrat doctoral un contrat doctoral
c'est un contrat de travail qui
correspond à un cdd de trois ans qui est
signée entre l'école doctorale d'une
université et le doctorant et pour
lequel est toujours là un salaire qui
tombent tous les mois et il fait sa
thèse dans ces trois années le problème
étant qu'en sciences sociales les tests
dure en moyenne cinq ans donc souvent à
la fin d'un contrat doctoral de trois
ans il y encore besoin d'une année voire
deux année pour finir la thèse donc les
doctorants qui bénéficie d'un contrat
souvent complète ce doctorat avec
démission d'oswald à terre à terre s'est
attaché temporaire d'enseignement et de
recherche c'est à dire qu'on est dans un
poste d'enseignement dans une université
à temps partiel ou à temps complet qui
va constituer un revenu dans les deux
dernières années de la thèse le contrat
doctoral c'est la voie royale du
financement de thèse même si on
s'accorde bien sur le fait que ce
salaire mais pas énorme mais pourquoi
c'est la voie royale parce que tout
simplement c'est là la voie la plus
stable ce qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'en
france à l'heure actuelle il ya à peu
près 20% des thèses en sciences sociales
qui sont financés via le contrat
doctoral alors qu'en sciences dites
dures c'est un système qui est beaucoup
plus répandu c'est lié à la dégradation
des conditions de travail à l'université
et aux conditions de financement des
thèses donc voilà ensuite le deuxième
moyen de financer une thèse de doctorat
c'est s'appelle la thèse en siffle donc
faire une thèse en chiffres c'est à dire
qu'on fait une thèse qui est financé par
une institution une organisation ou une
entreprise donc c'est un contrat de
travail là encore qui va être signée
entre l'université
le doctorant la doctorante et
l'organisme d'accueil donc là c'est une
thèse qui va être financée par une
entreprise dans l'optique d'obtenir des
résultats de recherche qui vont être
intéressants pour leur développement
après ça peut être aussi va des ong des
grandes organisations internationales
les institutions par exemple je sais que
la ville de paris finance des thèses en
siffler tous les ans il ya plein de
possibilités sur les thèses en siffler
et même si ce n'est pas toujours le cas
ça implique souvent qu'on fasse un
travail de terrain dans la structure
d'accueil c'est un système qui est très
intéressant puisque ben voilà il était
et organisation des institutions des
entreprises qui ont besoin d'eux de ces
résultats de la recherche après ça pose
aussi des questions sur l'éthique de la
recherche notamment en terme d'
objectivité ce qu'il peut y avoir des
conflits d'intérêts des choses qui ne
font pas plaisir à entendre pour sa part
d'organismes et ça pose également pas
mal de soucis en terme de répartition du
temps de travail et ces rapaces que dans
certaines structures il est attendu que
le ou la doctorante vraiment prennent
part à la vie de l'organisme d'accueil
de la structure d'accueil et donc les
frontières sont assez floues entre le
travail qu'ont fourni pour la structure
et le travail de recherche que l'on mène
grâce à la structure et la troisième
méthode pour financer sa thèse qui est
malheureusement en sciences sociales
aujourd'hui la méthode la plus
généralisée c'est ce qu'on appelle les
thèses hors contrat si vous ne savez pas
je fais partie de cette troisième
catégorie qui est la catégorie donc
majorité à des doctorants en france je
suis donc en thèse hors contrat et je
finance matin via des bourses alors
qu'est ce que c'est que système de
bourse c'est à dire qu'on à autorisation
de s'inscrire en doctorat dans une école
doctorale on paye d'ailleurs des frais
d'inscription je dirais précisé des
frais de scolarité est derrière et bien
il ne se passe rien un pantin de
financement c'est à dire que c'est à
nous doctorante et doctorants de
répondre à des appels à candidatures
pour des financements de diverses
natures il ya beaucoup d'instituts de
recherche d'universités de programmes de
recherche qui propose des bourses
notamment des bourses de mobilité pour
aller sur des terrains à l'étranger et
serra mais souvent ce sont quand même
des bourses assez courtes par exemple
dans mon cas j'ai obtenu une bourse de 5
mois qui a été renouvelée une fois j'ai
obtenu également une pause de six mois
mais rien qu'entre ces deux bourses y
avait déjà les différences par exemple
la une où je touchais de l'argent tous
les mois sur la durée de ma bourse et
puis il ya aussi une bourse où j'ai
touché une avance de 75 % du montant
total de la bourse puis à la fin de la
mission après
rapport financier etc on est censé
verser les 20 restants il ya aussi les
bourses où on obtient un montant qui
nous est remboursé qu'une fois la
mission terminée donc ça implique
d'avancer les frais ce qui est pas
simple quand on n'a pas d'autre activité
rémunérée après il y à des bourses qui
sont beaucoup plus longues des bourses
d'un an voire deux trois ans mais voilà
vous le voyez c'est quand même un
système qui est assez bancale instable
et inconfortable pour les doctorants et
doctorante parce que tout simplement ça
implique qu'on que déjà on soit au
courant de quels types de bourses existe
donc ça demande un travail de veille sur
les appels à financement qui est
considérable et qui est assez épuisant à
mener concrètement ça implique aussi de
monter des dossiers qui sont à chaque
fois quand même assez lourd pour de très
nombreuses structures d'encaisser des
refus d'être dans
l'incertitude concernant l'avenir
économique la leur au champ de cette
vidéo je vous retrouve dans cette
situation assez inconfortable ou dans un
mois et bien je n'ai plus d'argent qui
va tomber sur mon compte en banque tout
simplement donc voilà après ça nous
incite à travailler à côté donc à donner
des cours à prendre les postes à temps
partiel il ya même des doctorats ne te
rendre clairement surtout la situation
où ils prennent un poste à temps complet
donc voilà c'est des situations qu'ils
sont mythe ingérable mais c'est la voie
qu'empruntent à une grande partie je
pensais de la majorité des doctorants en
sciences sociales aujourd'hui du fait de
la dégradation des conditions de travail
et de formation à l'université donc
voila quand on se lance sans thèse c'est
vrai que ce qu'on espère toutes et tous
je pense c'est obtenir un contrat
doctoral fait bas il faut bien avoir
conscience qu'aujourd'hui c'est
seulement une minorité des doctoriales
doctorante qui obtiennent sur contrat et
que la l'obtention même dudit contrat
heureusement ça fait dans des conditions
qui ne sont pas toujours très juste
puisque ben voilà il quand on demande à
des doctorants comment ils ont une heure
plus tard doctorales il y en a pour qui
ça a été des concours presque avec un
dossier puis d euros et 2 1 2e morale
même parfois pour d'autres ça a été
juste le directeur de thèse je la dépose
et est-ce qu'ils aient à me tiens vous
un signe et on comptera enfin voilà il
ya un espèce de flou entretenu autour de
la manière de perdre ces contrats
doctoraux qui en plus se juxtaposent
avec malades et des intérêts qui sont au
dessus de nous en tant que dr on à dr
endres c'est à dire des conflits entre
labos entre direction thèse gens qui
s'aiment bien qu'ils s'aiment pas qui
veulent se rendre la pareille en bresse
un peu vide nous dépasser et
malheureusement ça n'a plus tant que ça
à voir avec la qualité des projets de
tête donc vous l'aurez compris les
doctorants ne roule pas sur l'or loin de
là c'est une voix
assez précaire même pour ceux qui sont
en contrat doctoral d'ailleurs c'est
triste à dire mais quand on se lance un
doctorat on sait à quoi s'attendre on
sait qu'on fait pas ça pour s'enrichir
clairement et on sait qu'on va traverser
des périodes assez compliqué voici vous
voulez vous vous lancez un doctorat
franchement tenter les contrats
doctoraux c'est vraiment là trop c'est
que je pourrais vous donner tenté dans
plusieurs écoles doctorales etc et puis
et ben si vous vous sentez les épaules
en fait pour vous lancer dans cette voie
là et vivre avec toute cette instabilité
cette insécurité qui est générée par les
évolutions dans nos revenus à cette
forme d'incertitude permanente qui plane
sur nous voilà c c'est triste à dire
mais ça fait partie du jeu aujourd'hui
j'en vois toutes mes bonnes ondes à mes
collègues doctorants et doctorante
qu'ils ne sont pas financés qui sont
hors contrat parce que on traverse à
plus ou moins toutes et tous les mêmes
choses et je sais combien c'est
compliqué donc bref tout ça pour vous
dire que je pense que c'est vraiment
super important d'avoir conscience de ce
que c'est que de vivre
en doctorat avec ce type de financement
avant de vous lancer parce que sinon ça
peut vraiment être con expérience est
très compliqué si vous n'êtes pas au
courant de ce à quoi vous vous exposez
tout simplement alors maintenant qu'on a
mis cela au clair on va pouvoir passer à
autre chose donc la prochaine question
c'est que peut apporter une thèse
personnellement et professionnellement
de manière assez basique la thèse de
doctorat nous permet d'accéder au grade
de docteur des universités le doctorat
est un diplôme qui est valorisé dans
certaines sphères professionnelles mais
qui permet surtout de s'inscrire ensuite
aux concours parce qu'il ya aussi des
concours après la thèse veulent accéder
aux postes de maître ou maîtresse de
conférences puis deux professeurs de
l'université etc etc donc en fait ce qui
me permet d'évoluer dans le milieu
universitaire après
ce que ça va passer un épanouissement
intellectuel tout simplement parce que
on évolue dans le milieu universitaire
avec des chercheurs de très haut niveau
on évolue auprès d'étudiants et
d'étudiantes qu'on conseille qu'on
accompagne c'est très épanouissant
forcément d'évoluer dans ces sphères là
et ce qui est pas nous ici c'est d'avoir
une multitude d'activités puisqu'on va à
la fois évolué dans le milieu
universitaire communiqué d'un mini
werther donc présenter nos recherches
mais également faire du terrain donc
elle dans des sphères totalement
différente du monde universitaire fois
il ya plein d'aspects pour lesquels
c'est vraiment super enrichissant à la
fois personnellement et
professionnellement et j'ai avec le
point le plus important c'est tout
simplement ce sentiment d'avoir une
activité professionnelle qui apporte à
ce monde
pas qu'ils aient un sens en fait pour la
société en tout cas moi c'est le choix
qu'a hier que je vais parce que c'est là
où je pense être à ma place et apporter
quelque chose d'ailleurs à ce sujet on
va poser une autre question qui aiment
que peut apporter une thèse dans son
domaine d'étude alors la thèse de
doctorat simplement elle contribue à
documenter un fait social et à enrichir
la littérature à ce sujet en confrontant
des théories à
du concret quoi après il faut savoir que
la thèse de doctorat c'est pas non plus
l'oeuvre d'une vie ce sera la joueuse la
plus lue par contre quand on publie sa
tête c'est à dire qu'on en fait un livre
à l'issue de la soutenance et bien c'est
vrai que là on atteint un électorat un
peu plus large donc voilà c'est ce qu'on
apporte avec la thèse puis les
publications qui découle de la thèse et
bien c'est d'enrichir la science de
participer à la production des savoirs
et des connaissances sur un sujet où
dans un champ théorique
donc voilà c'est ça qu'on apporte à son
à sa discipline est la dernière question
pour cette première catégorie c'était
quels sont tes motivations pour coiffer
rétaise malgré tout la violence que vive
les doctorants et des doctorantes alors
mes motivations donc je pense qu'on a
déjà un petit peu parlé mais de rien
c'est le fait de voir évoluer dans de
l'universitaire de vouloir contribuer à
la production des savoirs de documenter
une réalité sociale d'être utile à mon
niveau dans la société donc les
violences que vivent les doctoriales
doctorante je pense que c'est important
qu'on en parle un petit peu je pense que
la première violence dont j'ai parlé
sans utiliser ce mot c'est la violence
économique c'est d'imposer une précarité
donc ça james économique elle exclut de
fait très nombreuses personnes du
doctorat et elle pousse vers la sortie
des doctorants qui sont pourtant très
bons dans ce qu'ils font et qui ont déjà
bien avancé dans leurs recherches à
cette violence économique peuvent
s'ajouter des violences qui sont en fait
une haie rentrent à de très nombreux
milieux professionnels mais qui c'est
vrai dans le milieu universitaire sont
vraiment généralisée et dont on ne parle
pas il ya plusieurs facteurs qui font
que ces violences existent et se
maintiennent notamment le fait que en
tant que doctorants de tentes on peut
très vite se retrouver isolé il ya de
très nombreux cas notamment de
harcèlement de violences sexistes et
sexuelles dans le milieu universitaire
formes dans tous les milieux j'ai envie
de dire mais le canton croiser les
autres types de violence donc le fait se
retrouver isolé d'une part et en plus
parfois la précarité ou le fait qu'on ne
soit pas en train de travailler dans le
cadre contrat de travail et bien
forcément ça rend ces violences d'autant
plus forte et surtout ça ne facilite pas
les recours il ya un livre notamment qui
a beaucoup fait parler de lui récemment
donc c'est ce livre de adel b combes
comment l'université broie les jeunes
chercheurs précarité harcèlement loi du
silence voilà tout est dit dans ces
trois mots clés sait jamais vous vous
trouvez actuellement dans l'une de
situation n'hésitez pas à consulter la
base d'informations je vous mets des
ressources pour avoir accès à des
recours et donc pourquoi j'ai fait des
zones malgré ce contexte et bien tout
simplement parce que je reste quelqu'un
de très enthousiaste par rapport à la
recherche à tous que l'avis scientifique
est extrêmement importante dans une
société et j'ai la chance d'avoir une
direction de thèse exemplaire dessus
également bien entouré en deux autres dr
avec qui je travaille donc je me rends
compte pas ce genre de difficultés je
rends compte la violence économique
comme je vous en ai parlé c'est un choix
que j'ai aussi construit je me suis pas
lancé tête baissée en doctorat j'avais
conscience ce vers quoi elle jallet ça
n'empêche que c'est inadmissible
pourtant on va donc passer à la deuxième
catégorie de questions et parler des
sujets un petit peu plus léger en
voisine donc ce sont toutes les
questions concernant la motivation au
quotidien et mon organisation dans le
travail alors pour commencer on m'a
demandé d'écrire une journée il n'y a
pas de journée type en doctorat tout
simplement parce que en
multiplie les casquettes on va dire en
tant que doctorants et donc les journées
ne se ressemblent pas c'est une des
raisons pour lesquelles j'adore le
doctorat d'ailleurs on va dire que
j'identifie trois types de journée le
premier type de journée que je vais
avoir et qui est quand même le type de
journée le plus fréquent c'est la
journée lecture écriture donc c'est la
journée typiquement que je le passais à
mon bureau à lire des articles master à
écrire des réflexions théoriques ou des
rapports de ce qui s'est passé sur le
terrain et dans quelques mois ou années
ce sera aussitôt d'apathie où j'écris ma
thèse ça va aussi être les journées où
j'écris mes dossiers pour des demandes
de financement que j'écris des rapports
pour des fins de bourse ou de
financement très complices et occupe une
grande partie de mon temps
c'est tout simplement le fait d'être à
sa table de travail devant son
ordinateur d'écrire de lire de répondre
à des mails voilà tout ce genre de
choses ensuite la deuxième journée type
ça va être la journée terrain donc les
journées terrain elles sont vraiment
propre à chacun dans mon cas j'ai un
terrain qui est donc dans des zones
agricoles des zones rurales donc ça
implique que je me déplace et que je
reste sur place plusieurs journées
al'inverse du premier type de journée
certains journaux je vais te or pas du
tout sur mon ordinateur à faire des
interviews afin de l'observation
participante dans des structures
agricoles je vais également rencontré
des universitaires voilà je vais être
plongés en immersion sur mon terrain et
avoir la casquette d'intervieweuse et
enfin la troisième journée type ça va
être la journée vie académique c'est ce
qui concerne les événements de la vie
scientifique par exemple des colloques
des conférences des séminaires auxquels
on assiste pour voilà apprendre plus sur
notre sujet rencontrer les chercheurs
qui travaillent sur des problématiques
similaires et ça m'a aussi le fait
d'aller à présenter ne recherche ou du
moins une partie de nos recherches dans
des événements scientifiques
comment s'articulent à 6 3 6 2 journées
je pense que vraiment 80% le montant est
vraiment la journée lecture écriture au
charmant bureau et ensuite les 20%
restants se divisent peut-être en 15%
terrain et 5% de vinyle six ter voilà je
pense que grosso modo c'est ça est ce
que j'adore c'est d'avoir l'equilibre
détroit qui se créé parce que je
m'épanouis beaucoup dans les trois types
d'activités ainsi on me demande si j'ai
un système d'organisation alors je vais
pas vous détailler tous mon organisation
parce que je les ai déjà fait tout
simplement dans une vidéo à laquelle je
vous renvoie je vous mets le lien en
barre d'infos ont demandé comment
gères-tu tes données bibliographiques
dans son élan thèse il y à un sujet
extrêmement important qui est la
bibliographie et on est amené à lire de
très nombreux artistes donc si vous êtes
en tête mais mon mémoire pour un mémoire
de master et caetera et que vous
n'utilisez pas de logiciel des
bibliographies vraiment fait le savent
absolument vous savez je te laisse
zotero c'est l'un des logiciels de
traitement de sources de traitement de
bibliographie qui existe j'ai pas essayé
les autres j'ai été vers zotero parce
qu'on en avait parlé et voilà nous
sommes convient très bien je me trouve
dans la barre d'infos il ya pas mal de
vidéos sur youtube qui sont nés tutoriel
d'utilisation de zotero la progression
savoir comment je fais pour gérer
sociologue hausse à côté de ma thèse en
fait ça c'est intéressant parce que
sociologue c'est vraiment partie
intégrante de mon organisation dans la
thèse j'ai lundi que c'était vraiment
intégré à mon rythme travaille dans le
sens où évidemment produire une vidéo
youtube me demande énormément de travail
le passent des heures et des heures à
faire rire la sociologue ça m'apporte
énormément dans le sens où la thèse
c'est beaucoup de travail au quotidien
dont on ne voit pas le résultat tout de
suite puisque bas le produit fini de ma
thèse je le verrai dans deux ans et demi
trois ans si tout va bien et du coup là
de pouvoir me dire je me saisis d'un
sujet je fais mes lectures je préfère la
vidéo je l'attends jam ont déjà publie
et bien finalement c'est quelque chose
qui se fait dans le temps court voilà si
je me motive en une deux semaines je
peux avoir produit une vidéo donc ce
côté va du produit fini cette action
d'aller au bout d'une action est de voir
le résultat rapidement c'est tellement
décalage avec le temps très long de la
recherche à la publication scientifique
et universitaire c'est vraiment
satisfaisant et en plus d'avoir vos
retours la cuban page et je trouve
beaucoup de sens c'est quelque chose qui
me motive et l'autre chose qui m'aide
avec sociologue c'est que dans une
journée type admettons je avoir un coup
de barre dans ma journée à 16 heures
j'ai fais que lire toute la journée et
puis voilà j'ai un peu plus d'heureux
d'aller me poser dans le canapé avec une
série et bien je vais me motiver pour
bosser sur sociaux logos préparer des
visuels pour instagram possession le
script d'une vidéo faire du montage etc
ça me permet de passer deux heures à
faire autre chose de ma thèse mais comme
m est en train de travailler comme ça
après je peux me remettre ça m'aide à
garder un côté productifs tout en
stimulant aussi mon côté créatif ça qui
est important pour moi ça c'est pour ça
que je gère sociaux le russe a coûté
c'est aussi parce que ça me fait du bien
et ça m'aide dans mon organisation après
je me suis aussi fixer une règle avec
sociaux logos c'est que je ne me
forcerai pas à poster que ce soit des
passants s'aggrave des story ou des
vidéos si je sens que c'est pas un
moment que j'en ai pas envie que j'ai
pas le temps je me suis pas imposé un
rythme de publication je sais que ça
limite la dynamique que pourrait avoir
ma chaîne tout mon activité sur ce sujet
logos je la fais de manière bénévole
c'est une activité secondaire par
rapport à ma thèse et je souhaite que ça
reste ainsi moins pour le moment ensuite
on m'a demandé quel est le meilleur
moment du doctorat et pourquoi la fin
moi j'apprécie vraiment le processus
j'espère que ça va continuer sur cette
lancée et le moment que je préfère du
tout aura je dirais que c'est en ce
moment parce que quand j'ai commencé
j'avais quand même ce côté où j'étais un
peu perdu dans ma bibliographie dans ce
que je voulais faire dans ce que je
voulais dire et en plus j'avais pas trop
d'accès au terrain du fait de de la
crise sanitaire je dirais qu'en ce
moment j'aime beaucoup mon doctorat
parce que commence à vraiment savoir là
où je vais j'ai conscience une
conscience plus précise de ce qu'est mon
objet d'étude de ce qui va me permettre
de dire je commence à vraiment me sentir
à l'aise en le sujet me sentir sûr de ce
que je dis je prends de l'assurance en
fait tout simplement surtout les toutes
les thématiques avec lesquels je
travaille c'est une phase qui est très
agréable au niveau intellectuel parce
que c'est très stimulant et en même
temps on se rend compte du chemin
parcouru depuis le début de la thèse
mais c'est aussi une phase compliquée je
voulais de la division financement donc
voilà jamais rien qui est parfait dans
le doctorat mais je pense que c'est
pareil dans la vie de manière générale
en tout cas mon moment préféré basse et
en ce moment il ya une autre question
qui est assez proche qui m'a été posée
c'est ton moment préféré de ta thèse
pour l'instant donc dans cette question
j'ai l'impression qu'on me demandez
plutot il y avait un événement une
journée un passage de la grèce qui m'a
particulièrement plu franchement c'est
pas facile de choisir mais je pense que
le moment qui a été le plus précieux
dans ma thèse jusqu'à présent ce serait
peut-être certaines journées sur le
terrain parce que quand ça se passe bien
c'est du contact humain qui est génial
tout simplement voilà c'est part à la
rencontre de nouvelles personnes et moi
j'aime beaucoup ça et bien voilà j'ai
répondu à vos questions sur la thèse
j'espère que ces petits moments passés
en ma compagnie à vous aura plu je vous
remercie encore une fois d'être présent
sur la chaîne je vous invite à vous
abonner à mettre un gem à cette vidéo à
la partager à faire vivre sociale aux
bulls je vous retrouve très bientôt pour
une nouvelle vidéo sur ces logos
[Musique]